argent drogue violence à pouvoir et
trahisons matin nous plonge au coeur de
la mafia sicilienne montréalaise du
début des années 90 soit ce transfert le
clash moon soo choo manjak une pareille
pour le six prochains mois marc andré
grondin y interprète un ambitieux
criminel un ami d'enfance du fils du
parrain jean personnage qui est sur
papier très difficile à aimer je pense
ce qui est beaucoup c'est ce qu'on se
permet dans le film de montrer d'où il
vient puis qu'est ce qui a fait en sorte
que ce personnage lui est devenu la
personne qui est devenu le film dépeint
l'univers impitoyable dans lequel
évoluent des criminels endurcis que le
réalisateur podz réussi à rendre humain
sur ces histoires de deux femmes et puis
en fait deux façons de voir la vie très
différente
puis il ya ainsi comme souhaite pour
arriver à des fins plans énoncés
diffèrent
j'espère que les fans arrivent à toi qui
suit le par hull par une balle d'une
balbi combat je citerai pas je puis vous
voir déficit hamoudi de famille de ben
10 au final vincent mon personnage
cherche une famille cherche pied réussis
pas le trouver dans sa famille à lui
puis la mafia bros qui arrivent
généralement mafia est une fiction
inspirée d'un livre du même nom consacré
habite au résultat c'est ce qu'à des
cinq sont amplifiées là dedans pour des
besoins cinématographique mais
l'ensemble ce qui ressort de ça on peut
voir beaucoup beaucoup l'esprit d'un
film devrait comprendre qu'on va faire
beaucoup plus d'argent collaboreront
pour que les gens soient sensibilisés
elle va faire comment ça fonctionne et
tout ça parce que c'est très insidieux
la mafia c'est trafic de drogue est tous
assez c'est un élément mais le côté des
le côté de la shdm en d'argent c'est ça
qui est inquiétant c'est ce qu'est ce
qui moi je pense qu'il est important que
les gens sachent que vous êtes le
parrain de la mafia cannon
mafia inc est un film de fiction
captivant qui fait la lumière sur un
univers bien réel et à glacer le sang
d'ici là bien lexandre charti radio
canada montréal